okay I've got something really really
great for you today you might remember
that at different times on the show in
order to grow our membership support we
will offer half price memberships and
the way this usually works is someone
gets in touch and they say hey David
I've got $500 that I want to use to
sponsor some memberships how can we
stretch this the farthest possible and
what I'll usually say is great let's
take that $500 let's pay for half of a
bunch of memberships and then people can
write in and say I want a membership for
30 dollars instead of 60 a generis
generous Good Samaritan pays for 30
bucks and then we have a bunch of $30
memberships available the $500 becomes
$1,000 literally everybody wins it's not
zero-sum everybody wins
I have available for you today a lot of
half-price memberships this is not even
like one to ten twenty thirty Joshua who
is a David Pakman show
all-star supporter he's a member he's a
super chat supporter on my youtube live
streams he's a patron he's the whole
thing he got in touch and he said I want
to do something big I wanted something
really really big um so he has funded a
whole bunch I don't even need to tell
you how many right now because we've got
a long runway of these half-price
memberships and if you want one of these
half-price memberships he's being really
really generous please contact me now we
are committed to actually putting this
money to work so it's not just like a
donation we keep no matter what we've
got to allocate the funds to memberships
that people are getting at half price
Joshua's paying for 30 bucks if you want
the membership for 30 bucks right in and
I will get you that membership but and
this is something that is above and
beyond generous Joshua also said that I
can give away some free memberships as
well not half price just straight-up
free for people who truly can't afford
half price now I'm not gonna ask for
your tax returns we're not going to do
anything like that
if you truly can't afford a half-price
membership and you want one okay get in
touch
we have free memberships available for a
year
thanks to Joshua but I'm saying with
peace and love
let's all be reasonable people about it
if you can afford a half price
membership ask for the half price
membership 30 bucks for an entire year
of content it's like 2 dollars and 70
cents a month it's a really reasonable
price to allow more free memberships to
remain for people who really can't
afford the half price memberships ok so
this is absolutely awesome thanks to
Joshua let's do it go to david
pakman.com and click the contact button
or i'm managing these personally I am
your personal membership concierge on
this deal email me david at david
pakman.com the caveat is you've got to
spell my last name right if you spell it
Parkman or Pakman with a c' or Pakman
with a CK I won't get the emails but a
massive massive thank you to Joshua who
has been really generous this year half
price memberships available a lot of
them ok so right in 30 bucks for the
year if you really can't afford that if
the only way is a free membership Joshua
is okaying a limited number of
absolutely and totally free memberships
get in touch and to the extent that they
remain available on a first-come
first-served basis I will get you the
information you need to sign up for one